Anthony Davis that almost went down
who's out there baby seven-point game
Rondo knew it right away till the
defense and he saw that only the top and
here's a team running the floor and
Rondo delivering I mean that's just
pretty pretty basketball put right now
the way Rondo is playing he just keep
impression
over the top pretty pretty basketball
put right now the way Rondo's playing
he's just keeping pressure over the top
amigo keep it up in the neighborhood was
a 16 wide lead for the towels over the
top beautiful set up by trill holiday
brew in particular have done that over
the first two you're going to have
success ad litem 5 go
they overplayed by Aminu to be a
basketball play right there this is the
basketball play over the top to ad and
how about that group took it away he's
got it in Clark and see the spacing
nobody they're going to 380
[Applause]
phanie Davis and the numbers just left
this would let this breathe right here
of the 107-foot the palace it'll be
through holiday how about AZ why not
having some fun out there big boy back
[Applause]
it's time to shut this down
we can get a subpoena